(calm soothing music)
- Hi everyone, my name is
Heinrich from Firm Learning,
and welcome back to my channel
where I want to help you
to be successful in the
first years of your career.
If you find what I'm having
to say at all useful,
please consider giving me a
like by clicking the Like button
here below the video, and
if you would like to see
more videos like that where
I bring you my perspective
from having worked at
over six years at McKinsey
for how you can be
successful in the first years
of your career, please
subscribe to this channel,
and you will receive all of the videos,
and also press the Notification
button to always receive
a notification whenever
I upload a new video.
Today, I got inspired by Victor Cheng,
and if you don't know him, check him out.
He has a website, caseinterview.com,
where he helps people
to master the consulting case
interviews, great resource,
check it out, caseinterview.com,
and I received a newsletter
from him where he talked about
the topic Problem Talker
Versus Problem Solver.
He contrasts two type of people;
those who talk about problems
and those who actually
solve problems, and this was
a topic that resonated with me
a lot because I observed these two
different types of mentality
a lot in the last years.
I've seen these type of
people, and when I read this,
I completely agreed that
this is what is going on
and that these are the two types of people
that are out there, and trust
me, one of these two types
is clearly better than the
other, and I'd like to help you
understand the differences,
and also give you some tips
how you can rather become a problem solver
than just a problem talker,
what the differences are,
and why this is so important,
why all organizations
need lots and lots of problem solvers,
but problem talkers aren't
really what is interesting
and necessary and helpful to the people.
So, what are problem talkers,
to start with this group of people?
Problem talkers like
to talk about problems.
They like to identify problems,
to see them, and to describe them.
So, Victor Cheng here gives three examples
of what problem talkers do.
Let's just go over some of them.
So it's, for instance, somebody who says,
"Boss, this budgeting process
is just so inefficient,
"there's no use of it,
and it's just wasting
"everybody's time," right, this would be
a typical statement of a problem talker.
Or, "Hey, the way that we
orient on new employees,
"the way that we onboard
them, just doesn't work,
"it's not efficient and not working
"for these new colleagues," or
Is driving throughout a city
and you say, "Hey, this
tree is just hanging
"in front of the stop sign,
this is so unprofessional.
"Somebody needs to do something about it.
"Somebody needs to inform the
city, this needs to change
"because it's just unsafe," right?
So, these are typical things
that problem talkers will do,
and it's just really
important to understand
the psychology behind all that.
Why would people behave in this way?
Well, and I think an important
and the key part of that
is that it's because it makes
these people feel intelligent,
feel smart, "Hey, I'm the
one who identified this,
"I got this, obviously
everybody else cannot see this
"because the problem
was still there, right,
"but I'm the one who got
this, I identified it,
"and if everybody would
be as smart as I am,
"then things like that would not happen."
I think this is a characteristic
of such a problem talker
that the way that he
sees the problems is that
these problems are always
caused by the other people.
The other people are
responsible for these problems,
but it's never the problem
solver, and if only
these other people would
do their jobs right,
the problems like that
wouldn't exist, right?
If only the other people
would take their job
as seriously as the problem talker does,
then the world would
be a much better place.
So, let's now contrast that
with how a problem solver
would approach these types of situations,
and as the name says, the problem solver
does not only talk about all
the things that need to change,
but he actually tries to make a difference
and to make an impact,
and to actually change
and solve these problems,
and yes, it is true
that very often it is just
not possible that you,
as one person, organization,
can solve all the problems
by yourself, even though I
would say the people frequently
underestimate the impact
that they actually can have
if they really, really
wanted to make a difference.
But yes, it is true that
this is not possible,
but then what the problem solver does is,
at least he does not only
try to come up, at least,
with an idea or a suggestion
how it could work,
but he also tries to go the
first steps in that direction
to not only come up with, yeah obviously,
this is what would need
to happen, but also
to go in the first steps in that direction
to actually make that a reality.
And, let's now go over these examples
that we just discussed a bit earlier
about how a problem solver
talks about the problems.
Let's go over these examples,
what the problem solver
now actually could do,
and now starting with
the budgeting process,
the problem solver would
not only say that the
budgeting process doesn't work,
but he would make a couple of suggestions
of how the budget process
could actually improve,
and what substantiate these suggestions,
maybe talk to some colleagues to make sure
that this really makes sense, and then,
you wouldn't stop here,
but he then would reach out
to the person who actually
is responsible for shaping
the budgeting process, and
then just proposes to him,
just in an open and
constructive way, raises topic
and just make a few ideas
how this could change,
and if you do not do that
in a confrontive way,
very frequently you will
see that people actually
quite responsible for good
ideas because these good ideas
then hopefully make the
work and the life easier
for everybody who was involved, right,
so why wouldn't then
the person responsible
for the budgeting process
not take on that idea?
So, he goes that step in that direction.
The other example was
the onboarding process
for new employees that
apparently just did not work,
so what would a problem solver do?
He would not only complain
about the onboarding process
that wouldn't work,
but he would just start
creating a few documents,
maybe a checklist
that new employees can use.
And that order for them
that the onboarding process
would be a bit more
smoothly and more helpful,
so some resources, for
instance, that he would've
found helpful when he joined the company,
and then once he gives this
to a couple of colleagues
in his direct team that maybe
then you'll join us then.
If this picks up and people
see that this is helpful,
very likely has an awesome opportunity
to push this to the larger
department, or maybe even
the whole organization because
he just made an impact there,
and this will show an
initiative, and this is how
he really can solve these problems.
Or, the third example was
the example with the tree
that is hanging in front of the stop sign,
where the problem solver
now could just call the city
and let them know that
this problem exists,
let them know where exactly
the street is located,
where exactly it is
covering the stop sign,
and pretty likely then the city,
once it has been officially informed,
it will do something
about it, and make sure
that this tree then gets
taken away from the stop sign,
and now the safety is restored again.
So, these are things that
problem solvers would do.
They try to solve the
problem, and they do not only
talk about the problems,
and from my experience,
problem solvers like
that belong to the most
valuable people that
organizations can have.
Organizations can never
have enough problem solvers,
but pretty much do not
need problem talkers
because the reality is that,
even though the problem talker
maybe believes that he is so smart
because he sees the
problem, pretty usually,
these problems are perceived
by many, many people,
but the reality is that
most of these people
don't do anything about them.
Most people are problem talkers,
but only very few people
are problem solvers, that's
just the truth, guys.
In fact, this is just natural.
This is how we humans behave.
We tend to believe that
if there's a problem,
it's not because of us, but
it's because of other people
who made the mistake, and it's something
that I sometimes catch myself as well.
If I watch myself, I see that I have
such a thought that there's a problem,
and probably somebody else
is responsible for that,
but if I'm really honest to
myself, I know and I understand
that I would have the
power to do something
about that as well, and this
would be now my advice to you.
Whenever you have such
a thought in your head,
this is going bad, this doesn't work,
these idiots from the other department,
why aren't they doing a better job?
Always ask what can you do,
what do you have in your power
to actually make a difference
and to make an impact
for your organization, because
if you adopt that mindset,
you will not only be a problem talker,
but you will be a problem solver,
and this is what organizations will value,
and this is how you will be successful
in the end as an employee and as a person
in your whole life, I would say.
So, thank you for watching.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please press the Like button below,
and if you would like to
see more videos like that
where I try to help you to be successful
in the first years of your
career, please subscribe,
and also hit the notification there
to get a notification whenever
I release a new video.
Thank you for watching,
thank you for being
a loyal lIstener to my channel.
I very much appreciate that.
My name is Heinrich, I'm
here from Firm Learning.
Thank you, goodbye.